hey what is up everybody it's annamac
here for
anime uproar and in this video i will be
explaining the new
massive titan shifter reveals in the
attack on titan story this includes the
newly introduced
flying titan a mythical titan shifter
that fans have been theorizing about for
many years
i will also explain how the story was
able to introduce
new never-before-seen titan shifters
even though we already know the holders
of all nine current
titan shifters all of that and more
is coming up in this video if you
enjoyed the attack on titan content here
on the channel and you want to see more
please leave a like
and comment to let me know you might
think that liking and commenting doesn't
matter but it actually helps us out a
lot because it tells youtube to promote
this video to more people
and if you're new to the channel or
maybe you just haven't subscribed yet
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell
to turn on all notifications oh and if
you're enjoying that
epic music in the background it's
actually an amazing cover of the iconic
fogle mk fight from attack on titan
by grissini project just listen to how
beautiful this
[Music]
is
that is freaking insane definitely check
out the grissini project
and show them some love the link to
their youtube channel is down
in the description they didn't pay me to
promote them or anything i was just so
amazed by their work that i wanted to
shout them out
finally this video will contain attack
on titan manga spoilers so please
proceed with caution
you have been warned now ever since we
first learned about the nine titan
shifter powers
in attack on titan fans have been
speculating about the potential for a
flying titan to show up
at some point in the future however once
the final shifter was introduced which
was of course the warhammer
titan most of us assumed that we would
never see
a flying titan shifter none of the known
shifters had any flying capabilities and
there was no clear indication that there
could ever be
a flying titan but that all changed once
we got to chapter 133
of the manga but before we talk about
that we need to talk about falco grice
and his jaw titan power when we first
meet him
falco is a marlin warrior candidate who
is hoping to be chosen to succeed reiner
as the next armored titan but all of his
plans change when he is abducted along
with gabby
and taken to the island of paradise
while on parodies
falco accidentally ingests some of the
wine that was
tainted with zeke's spinal fluid and so
once
zeke eventually uses his scream to
transform a bunch of the aldians on the
island into pure titans
falco is transformed as well as a pure
titan
falco has no control of his actions and
during the course of the subsequent
battle
falco's pure titan ends up eating porco
galliard which gives falco the power of
the jaw titan
falco is then able to return to his
human form
and the first time he transforms into
his new jaw titan form
it is clear that his jaw titan has some
distinct
bird-like features including talons and
an
outer jaw that resembles a beak at first
i didn't think that these bird-like
features had
any significant meaning all of the jaw
titans that we've seen thus far have
been very unique and very
different from each other so i thought
that falco's
titan was probably just unique to him
and i thought that his appearance was a
nod to the name
falco which means falcon in latin
but in chapter 133
falco says something that is extremely
interesting and something that ends up
being
extremely important falco says that he
had a vivid dream that felt
more like a real memory only not his
memory it appeared to be a memory that
falco inherited from zeke
through zeke's spinal fluid in this
dream
or memory falco sees himself flying
above the clouds and he concludes that
these are the memories of a previous
beast titan shifter now zeke's beast
titan is obviously an
ape but falco believes that in the past
the beast titan shifters
looked very different they weren't all
ape-like
some were based on completely different
beasts altogether
and falco believes that some beast
titans actually had wings
and were able to fly at this point falco
is convinced that his jaw titan has to
some extent
inherited the abilities of the previous
beast titans
through zeke's spinal fluid and this
leads falco to conclude that his
jaw titan has the potential to gain the
ability to fly
just like some of the previous beast
titans in the video that i made
on chapter 133 in particular i
speculated that falco would in fact
gain the ability to fly and i said that
i thought that he and annie would be
able to join the main battle against
aaron by flying up to him
using falco's flying jaw titan and
this is exactly what ended up happening
in chapter 135.
that's when we see annie and gabby ride
atop of falco's jaw titan to rescue
their allies from the new titan shifters
that emir fritz
sent after them in this new flying titan
form
falco's jaw titan has fully developed
wings
and it is able to easily carry at least
seven people on
its back while flying and this is how
the old
fan theory about a flying titan shifter
a theory that most fans abandoned after
all nine shifters were introduced and
none of them could fly
actually came true in chapter 135
and it wasn't the beast titan shifter
who gained the ability to fly by
becoming a flying
beast instead it was the jaw titan who
unlocked the ability to fly
due to falco's direct connection to the
beast titan shifter
through zeke's spinal fluid man this is
definitely not something that i expected
would happen before
falco inherited the jaw titan powers i
definitely wouldn't have thought that
the jaw titan out of all the titans
would be the one to unlock
the ability to fly but there you have it
fun fact way back in april of 2017 the
attack on titan's season 2 opening
clearly hinted at the fact that the
beast titan shifter can potentially take
on
many different beast forms we clearly
see the beast
titan running alongside a bunch of other
beasts including a crocodile
but more on the crocodile later in terms
of falco's jaw titan we know that he is
very strong fast and
agile just like the other jaw titans
but as of the making of this video we
still haven't seen his flying titan form
in action we've seen him fly and carry
his allies on his back
but we haven't seen him actually trying
to engage in combat
at least not yet but still the fact that
this titan can fly
is an absolutely huge deal this is a
game-changing ability that allowed annie
and falco to rejoin the main battle
after they had initially split up from
the rest of their comrades
and it is also an ability that will turn
out to be extremely important in the
fight against aaron's
absolutely gigantic new titan form
i mean falco's flying titan was already
able to save the lives of multiple
people
so you better believe that this power is
going to continue being useful during
the final
epic showdown and that is what we know
about falco's titan thus far
and that is how a jaw titan was able to
gain the ability to
fly i got a ton of questions about this
in the comments to my previous attack on
titan videos
so i wanted to answer all of those
questions here at least based on the
information that we have so far
on top of that i also got a lot of
questions about the new titan shifters
that appeared in chapter 135
i am talking about the shifters that
attacked the anti-aaron alliance as they
climbed aaron's gigantic titan in an
attempt to reach the physical bodies of
aaron and zeke these
are definitely titan shifters they are
not pure titans
and although many of them are new to us
because we've never seen them before
in reality they are old titan shifters
more specifically their previous titan
shifters that existed at some point
between the death of emir fritz
and the present time these former
shifters were resurrected by emir fritz
and sent to attack
the anti-aaron alliance in an effort to
protect aaron from harm
among these former titan shifters we see
some titans that we can recognize
including the former jaw titan rest in
peace porco
the former warhammer titan and the
former colossal titan
but we also see shifters that we've
never seen before
including a beast titan who looks like a
crocodile
and we also see what appeared to be
previous armored titans
warhammer titans jaw titans and so on
seeing all of these former titans
attacking some of our favorite
characters was both
kinda cool and absolutely terrifying
and to be honest i would love to know
more about all of these titan shifters
and their holders but will we ever learn
more about these former titans
probably not much since there is just so
much stuff going on in the main story of
attack on titan but
with that said we definitely will learn
more about
falco's new flying titan and i'm really
looking forward to that
now let me know what you guys think did
you like the flying titan twist
and were you expecting it did you think
that the twist made sense
in terms of the story the whole zeke
spinal fluid connection
or did you maybe think that it kind of
came out of nowhere
also do levi mikasa armin and the others
stand a chance against
aaron even with falco's flying titan
is there any way to defeat all those
overpowered
former titan shifters not to mention
aaron's gigantic
titan and finally how will this
incredible story
ultimately end don't forget to share
your thoughts
down in the comments below huge thank
you to
omarvin for letting me feature some of
his amazing attack on titan fan art
in my videos including this fan art of
falco's jaw
titan definitely check him out and show
him some love
the link to his twitter is down in the
description
and also thank you to my colorists who
helped bring our thumbnails to life
including one hooks and wildfire their
links are in the description as well
if you enjoyed this video and you want
to see more attack on titan content
right here on the channel
please leave a like to let me know it
really does help
and if you're new to the channel or
maybe just haven't subscribed yet
make this the video you subscribe and
hit that notification bell to turn on
all notifications you can also hit me up
on twitter
and instagram at anime uproar
big thank you to all of our anime
outpour patrons for making videos like
this one possible
special thank you to alpha sigma a
disciple of lord twego himself
and i can't forget all of our the one
tier patrons the ones who rise above
all other clans including ingrata
the world a quiet respect liam thompson
pate heffa
yx phoenix anime 987 emperor otaku
thomas jones
spidey life danelle baked buddhist
tungsten tarcus and denki kaminari
finally thank you also to our pro hero
tier patrons including the one and only
gilgamesh steelers angel cruz anatoly
kasatsuki
cricket xp joe stanton very gucci
jessica calefon
alicia octor bonnie parks hinokamian
water the red-haired raven florian
joanne garcia jack watches anime fat boy
games deadly saint matthew cruz and
anthony schreiber if you enjoy our
videos and you feel that they provide
value for you please consider supporting
us
on patreon even a single dollar gives
you access to our patron exclusive
discord
and your name will appear in our videos
along with these
legendary people as always thank you
guys so much for watching and until next
time
see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you